[Musique]
bonjour bonjour bonjour micheline
bonjour maïté bonjour seul je leur fais
non merci d'être venus nous rejoindre
aujourd'hui
aimer c'est un grand plaisir de venir
dans sur le plateau de la cuisine des
mousquetaires s'est il n'y a pas à me
remercier c'est tout à fait normal
nous disons merci infiniment parce que
jorge pino est un des plus grands noms
de la plus belle gastronomie française
et c'est beaucoup plus le dire parce que
c'est un artiste et georges feno choisi
respecte et mélange les saveurs comme un
peintre choisi ses couleurs et comme un
musicien mélange les sons et ça c'est
rare ici du grand art et bien mes films
je ne sais plus quoi dire devant tant
d'éloges
vous savez j'étais là et j'ai très peu
de modestie alors n'en abusez pas non
mais ça ne vous m'avez dit quand même
que vous ayez fait l'école des
beaux-arts et que vous avez longtemps
hésité entre la peinture et la cuisine
dont j'allais dire la gastronomie et
bien aujourd'hui on pourrait faire de la
peinture parce que vous nous avez
apporté des produits merveilleux de la
bretagne d'où vous venez
voilà parce que vous êtes installé je
crois entre la baule équiperont
exactement oui un petit peu à
l'intérieur des terres mais dans cette
dans ce beau département du morbihan
avec son golf et au 310 il ya 300 civils
dans le golfe du morbihan c'est vraiment
une région magnifique et un pays de
cocagne pour les produits y a que chez
lui au ces bruits oui c'est ça mais avec
nous aussi on fait du foie gras ouais
c'est bien on a une région qui s'appelle
des landes autour de nous et enfin du
foie gras voilà voilà bien aujourd'hui
on va pas faire du foie gras avec vous
mais je voudrais quand même préciser que
vous avez avec votre épouse fait la
réussite d'un relais châteaux qui porte
le nom de votre province et qui
s'appelle le bretagne
alors de là bas vous à fond
huîtres des rouges et enfin des
merveilles quelle recette avez vous
l'intention de confier à michael alors
j'ai confié le plus difficile à maïté et
ce bien malin parce que c'est une
experte de la caméra et paris je lui ai
confié ces quelques rouges et ses
concombres c'est thomas maling annonce
je vais faire des filets de rouget au
beurre de concombre et au basilic et
ensuite jorge pino du frein d'autres
recettes avec 18 et nous en reparlerons
jordi faut que je vous demande de nous
quitter et d'asthme anglais pour comité
travaille comme une grande doute trop
mal et ensuite on vous demander de venir
nous rejoindre à tout à l'heure si un
tout honneur
or que nous faut-il pour cette recette
de filets de rouget au papillotes au
basilic et au beurre de concours voilà
bien entendu il faut défiler gras peut
faire demander au poissonnier
il va vous les faire très gentiment bon
après il nous faut des concombres qu'on
a on a relevé les graines s'est révélée
aussi écopé d'une amende
voilà et après vous enlever les graines
se fait tout seul voirie hop voilà donc
les deux plateaux avaient enlevé les
graines pour une fois on innove un
mixeur tartine de voter et d'élire à la
cuisine et mouscron on va pas faire
autrement alors on le fait comme ça vous
prenez vos concombre va grossièrement
voulait couper puisqu'ils vont se saisir
et c'est tellement tendre vous ya aucun
problème
voilà c'est pas la peine de faire la
news ont pris ce n'est pas la peine là
je vais ni c'est ça allez vous vous
mettez le couvercle
et en avoir marre et voilà
voilà humanité quand ils seront mixés la
joie ils vont rendre un petit peu d'eau
alors on va les écouter
comment faites vous ou c'est très facile
quelques diana ne semble un peu mais
vous allez voir tiens il ya pas d mars
une fois jeté tout ce qu'on peut quand
même aller voilà c'est tout et voilà
alors je remets mon mixeur en place
voilà je prends le buzz qui part à vau
l'aimé bien mais quand même oui je le
met gentiment autour
je vais mettre du sel du poivre parce
que tout ça c'est très fade
vous avez eu à peu près une plaque de
250 g de beurre pour ça dépend de la
taille du coup on se connaît ou de
contrôle en gros c'est rôle et je remets
mon petit couverte qui est très facile à
faire mais vous voilà et ont tourné et
ensuite mérité il restera à faire ces
fameux petits gâteaux
je tenais une feuille d'alu voilà en
quarts et en quarts et que j'ai fini en
2 sur la diagonale sur la diagonale et
que je vais mettre sur la planche au mur
la planche comme ça après je prends mes
fils et que je vais gentiment placé
comme ceux ci par contre la diagonale un
petit peu serré et à la chevauchée jeu
serge poivre
mes deux petits fils et bien relevé j'y
mets un petit peu de basilic dessus si
le lait commencent isolé eh bien oui il
est ciselé hier qui n'est pas tout à
fait non j'en étais plus résilient quand
je vais poser au couteau ou aussi se
révéler mais qu'est ce que j'avais
ciselé mon dieu mon dieu mon dieu
bon alors je vais mettre le vrai qu il
ya aussi le bar d'un concombre il a eu
froid l'a embouti par et généreusement
mis au repos
il en faut aller mettre un petit poule
encore on va enlever celui là celui-là
il de notre part qu'on va le remonter
voilà alors et ensuite je mets ces
petites tomates concassées et peser bien
entendu avoir les effets pin et ça va de
soi et concassés pato pour ce que la
papillote et quand même se soit pas
s'être trop serré car je vais remettre
un petit soupçon ce point de poivre et
de sel sur l'automate il a relevé un
petit peu plus de vasily on s'amuse
comme des petites folles c'est joli
surtout à la racine a maintenant son
travail d'artiste heures alors là on
replie il faut que le chef comptable de
moins bon alors je vais me l'a retourné
pour la bonne raison que font nos
rappeurs vous êtes à main n'a pour
l'instant pas dire que je vais caché
arrivent et ils te merde et petites
mains fines est hors norme
je faire du tour les deux couturières
avis urgent et lun alors je pousse tout
ça je n'en ai plus besoin
je refais ici un bon pli même topo
pas compliqué il faut absolument pas
colère pas faire attention voilà il faut
fermer hermétiquement
donc il faut un autre petit tour les
jeux arabes à se révolter up or la
piqûre s'en fout à 180° de sa honda
minutes à 180° ça fait à peu près
thermostat numéro 6 et 12 minutes 10
minutes à des comédies voilà elle est
magnifique maïté euros pour un coup
d'essai c'est un coup de maître
regarde dit bientôt four et voilà le
résultat
et voilà le résultat c'est magnifique
george est un plat principal ou d'une
entrée ça c'est un plat principal parce
que y'a tout il ya les légumes il ya la
sauce il ya le élément principal quel
rouget savez c'est joli et ça sent bon
alors maintenant vous allez faites nous
préparer justement une entrée voilà
alors je vais prendre des produits
traditionnels du morbihan le produit
principal qui est lui très je vous prie
préparer des huîtres en paquet au beurre
émulsionner au citron et bien pour
réaliser ces magnifiques paquet
d'huîtres il nous faut d'abord des
épinards oui alors selon la saison
l'idéal bien sûr c'est d'avoir des
épinards de printemps parce qu'ils sont
très tendres mais c'est difficile
en d'autres saisons de les blanchir en 2
ou 3 saisons il est blanchi c'est à dire
qu'on les passe à l'eau bouillante en en
enlevant la mer vue auparavant
bon ensuite naturellement plein doute
farida alors bien sûr il faut des
huîtres qu'on a ouverte
vous en voyez combien bref on compte il
faut compter la douzaine puisqu'on va
faire six paquets par personne et qui a
deux vitres par paquets donc référence a
fait la douzaine d'huîtres donc ses
huîtres ont été ouvertes et on les
laisse un petit peu dans l'euro qu'on a
filtré il y en a marre décortiqué après
les heurts et coquilles et vous avoir
sorti de la coquille et on les laisse un
petit peu dégorger dans cette eau pour
qu'elle perde un petit peu leurs débris
de coquilles mais on les a rincé ensuite
et alors qu'est ce que vous allez faire
pour que l'on s'y alors pour commencer
nous allons faire le beurre est
missionné 6 aux citrons qui va servir de
sauce à ce plat c'est un jeu d'enfant
mais chez nous à les voir c'est pas
grand chose
qu'est ce que vous mettez jamais une
goutte d'eau de 18 ans je vais mettre un
petit filet de citron
voilà pas plus que ça et après je vais
me mettre quelques parcelles de beurre
et je vais émulsionner ce beurre puisque
c'est un beurre émulsionner aussi 30
missionné ça veut dire monter jusqu'à ce
que l'on veut c'est de là que ça salit
quoi c'est une émulsion distincts stable
c'est un peu scientifique entre une
matière grasse est un élément liquide a
pas de tabou il faut il faut que ce soit
les limouxins de l'ébullition pour que
le beurre quand même se dissolvent mais
il faut pas que ça vous sans ça on va
déstabiliser
l'émulsion c'est simple on vous pourrez
regarder le show là bien sûr alors
maintenant je vais le garder au chaud
nous on veut tenir sur le point de vous
fournir en réalité et maintenant je vais
préparer les paquets avec les épinards
et avec les hits
pourquoi les feuilles d'épinard j'en ai
bien michel j'ai choisi des feuilles
d'épinard un petit peu par hasard c'est
une découverte que j'ai fait en créant
ce plat je me suis aperçu qu'il y avait
un espèce de phénomènes phénomène
d'osmose entre l'épinard et d'huîtres
canton poche une huître est des pertes
toujours un peu de son nom bien sûr elle
a tendance à se dessécher et l'épinard
qui est un légume très riche en humidité
restitue à l'huître l'humidité qu'elle
perd donc on a vraiment toutes les
saveurs de l'huître est tous les parfums
de l'huître est alors comment ce que
vous allez dire ça alors on va les cuire
dans une petite poêle
moi je vous ai tous préparés que maïté
va me va me passer et on va mettre donc
les vitres dans cette poêle
celle-ci manny pac est les petits
paquets d'accélération pour une personne
assez les rations pour une personne
c'est une entrée comme on disait tout à
l'heure c'est une entrée et on va
utiliser l'eau des huîtres qu'on va
filtrer parce qu'il peut y avoir encore
quelques débris mme au dessus de ses
huîtres et puis après ça on va remettre
sur le sur le brûleur sur le gaz elle a
été là nous mettre plein gaz ouvre et
elles couvrent parce qu'il faut cuire un
petit peu il faut laisser mitonné
séduite pendant environ 5 minutes de
façon à ce qu'elles fauche dans l'euro
et garder tout leur part vous les avez
sorti de la couenne
elles sont à point elles sont à point 5
minutes de cuisson ce sont les banques
les cinq dernières minutes
il faudrait alors on va dresser ce plat
on va écouter un petit peu les huîtres
même temps parce qu'il faut enlever
l'excédent
ils sont on les écoute un petit peu sur
ce papier absorbant et on les dispose
sur l'assiette et maïté va me passer
lover émulsionner mais avec plaisir et
nous allons taper tous à la faire ce
plat excellent vous savez ce qu'ils ont
pris leurs aises c'est une entrée vous
avez vu cette entrée convient de
réaliser qui va très bien se marier avec
les rouges et que maïté nous a préparés
tout à l'heure ça va faire un repas
absolument exquis ollada des bretons et
des bretons tout à fait on a cherché nos
impôts là on a heureusement que vous
retrouviez votre belle bretagne merci
oui et votre bel établissement qui
s'appelle la bretagne relais châteaux et
votre épouse aussi et mon petit fils aux
différents de succès mais on voudrait
énormément vous remercier maïté moi de
vous avoir rapporté ces deux beaux plats
c'est moi qui je suis ravi d'être venu
parce que ça m'a permis de faire
communiquer la bretagne un petit peu au
travers de la cuisine et bien au revoir
l'artiste au revoir michel retrouver vos
casseroles retrouver vos pinceaux et
nous viendrons vous voir et vous tous
n'hésitez pas à essayer c'était si
facile ces recettes un peu de soins et
beaucoup de bonheur au revoir à bientôt
[Musique]